في اسواقهم ترى جماليتهم وبراءتهم وطيبتهم
هنا في نيالا جنوب دارفور غربيه السودان
الاثار الاقتصاديه للاقتتال بين الجيش
والدعم السريع خلفت ركودا كبيرا لم يتوقعه
المنتجون منذ سنوات بعيده والله حركه
البيع يعني ما زي زمان الناس كلها شاده
يعني الناس امام ما في الحرب
الحرب شتت الناس كلها
المواصلات بقت بالف جنيه والمواصلات صعبه
في البيت انت بترقد تكون متقلقل تسمع صوت
السلاح 24 ساعه والذخيره وتعدني على ثاني
اكبر المدن في السودان المركز التجاري
الاضخم باقليم دارفور ونافذه عالميه للدول
المجاوره للبلاد
تهشم الامر فيها وادى الى توقف الحركه
التجاريه
باسواق الولايه اسعار زمان الشوال بتاعه
باميه بعشرين الف هسه بقت بعشره 12 ب 11
والطماطم كان بعشرين خمسه وعشرين هسه رجع
الى 15 18 17
واي خبر نزل هبوط شديد يعني هذا السوق كان
يعج بالحركه اصبح اليوم شبه خالي اذ لا
يمكن لاحد ان يوقظه من نومه وسط اصوات
الرصاص التي تسمع كل يوم والله خساره
كبيره
يعني يوم واحد ما بيتحمل لكن طبعا الحرده
امتدت هسه 22 يوم بالنسبه للحرب ده والناس
طلعت يعني طلعت من من في يدين ومن اي شيء
وطلعت من اموال ومن انفسهم يعني خايفين
بالنسبه لنفسهم يعني في بلد تج
را غياب الامن يعيده الى ايام توصف
بالمؤلمه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات